China's president Xi Jinping is expected
to meet Russian leader Vladimir Putin on
the sidelines of a summit in Uzbekistan
it will be the first time the pair have
met in person since the start of the war
in Ukraine she arrived on Wednesday and
was met by the Uzbek president
a lead is from the eight countries that
make up the regional block known as the
Shanghai cooperation organization a set
to discuss Global Security in the
expansion of beijing's belt and Road
initiative let's bring in Russell
certain who joins us now from summer
camp where the Summit is being held
Russell said the last time they met a
friendship with no limits was declared
what do we know about the discussions
this time around
well today there will be the the
bilateral meetings here but the most
important one seems to be the meeting
that's going to uh to take place between
uh the Russian uh President Putin and
the Chinese leader Xi Jinping so uh here
it seems that Ukraine war is is
overshadowing this Summit and during the
meeting between these two leaders Putin
is going to ask like a solid support
from China particularly regarding its
war in in Ukraine because so far China
based on on the experts that are telling
me China has not been providing the
support that Russia was seeking for but
besides the the support the demand for
support in the war in Ukraine Russia
also wants to increase the the export of
the gas and oil to China however China
is quite cautious here and yesterday uh
the Xi Jinping was in Kazakhstan and and
not that Kazakhstan is the second
largest gas exporter to China and China
wants to increase that gas from from
Kazakhstan to reduce its dependence to a
certain extent with Russia and also to
to provide to have more more
Alternatives in that case so Ukraine and
definitely the the the energy deal
between these two countries are going to
be on the top of the agenda and Russell
what about the summit itself what are
the broader aims
well it is the the largest uh the
regional uh cooperation organization in
the world so simply 40 of the world's
population and 30 percent of the global
GDP so and it is even during this this
Summit it wants to further expand so
Iran officially is start going to be
going to be the the the nearest member
and its membership is going to be
completed in April 23 in Belarus also is
in the line and officially the
membership process of Belarus is going
to start here we see that there are
eight member countries but also Observer
States uh The Observer States like
Belarus and Iran and also the dialogue
Partners like turkey Azerbaijan and
Armenia and also during this Summit the
Gulf States like Qatar and Saudi Arabia
are going to be the the the the partner
the the the the the the observative
other partners as well so here one of
the issue is that the experts are
telling us when it comes to Central
Asian countries their white coaches they
do not want to be turned into western
states of Russia and China however they
on the other hand want to keep their
good relationship and they do not want
to make this Summit look like an S West
anti-western Alliance as well so here
one of the interesting things that
happened just the the the the president
of the country was Pakistan
went to the airport to welcome Xi
Jinping however he didn't went to the he
didn't go to the airport to welcome
President Putin off Russia and experts
his are saying that this is actually the
preference General preferences of the
Central Asian country so the summit
definitely it's it's holding the world
leaders of this part of the world on the
other hand they are very much cautious
not to look like a anti-western Alliance
Russell thanks very much D for that
Russell there in some kind and
Uzbekistan thank you